maksim chmerkovskiy kept his engagement
to fellow dancing with the star pro peta
murgatroyd so top secret even his
brother Val wasn't in on the surprise
proposal days after max popped the
question to PETA ET caught up with the
newly engaged star to get all of her
wedding details Allison yes well you win
on that proposal no I was not you were
totally surprised no I found out
literally like half an hour before he
did that so there an intermission of all
of our show he uh it was like thought
I'd show me the ring and I bummed out
yeah you know we love Peter all jokes
aside I love her honestly with all my
heart and she's been part of the family
for a long time and I'm just glad that
that was a fish for food from Dancing
with the Stars family to in-laws PETA
now has some work to do to make sure Val
finds the woman of his dreams you know
they're putting a lot of pressure on me
especially my mom my mom has been like
well it's your turn out but Val isn't
sure he's ready to let her play
matchmaker said he tried this know as
the matchmaker I mean I've we've been
discussing a few things yeah what's it
come on yeah yeah I have you to
suggestions how do they go over I have
never been hooked up with somebody and
in working out and I really or not let's
note that that all like blind date like
friend of a friend never works out and
then I stopped being friends with a
friend so it's always over it